[Music]
hello and welcome to grand master's
choice i'm grandmaster
dennis borosch and today actually we're
going to
look at a special opening
if i tell you that there was an opening
invented
six years ago six
so not that long ago 2014 to be more
exact
and there are two people who were among
the inventors
one of them is surprisingly rob port
richard and ba'adur job
so guess that we're going to talk about
the rapport
joe bava variation and
for us to really understand the
nitty gritty of this opening we should
look at
the game that started at all and that
game is
between richard rapport and emil
sutovsky
in the olympiad so
d4 knight f6 knight c3
i still have to stop in this moment
because after d5 bishop f4
you're actually playing with the black
with the white pieces i know that sounds
shocking
at first glance but hear me out
so d4 d5 c4
knight c6 this is well known to be
the chigorin defense which chigoran
loved playing and later on picked up by
such legends as morozevich
and other very
good and aggressive players such as
richard rapport
so figuring that hey
if i'm playing this system with d4
knight f6
knight c3 d5 what if i play bishop f4
and the difference is kind of striking
actually white is playing a chi goran up
a tempo
they were wondering hmm would this
actually
give me a chance to get better as
white so as
richard rapport and his future wife
started experimenting with this but
the big and acid test came at the tromso
olympiad
where actually he gave it a go let's see
how it goes
c5 this is the real challenging try
what sutovsky plays he's trying to
kind of pick at the center e3
c takes d4 he takes d4 and i wonder
what would be your first thought what
would be the move that you would like to
play
here with black i know you might be a
little bit unfamiliar
with this position but i really like b
i'd really be curious to know what you
think
should be the best move here with black
don't forget development is important
however surprising as it may seem
development here
is losing on the spot knight c6 which
wasn't played is actually losing so
you're
lost on move five how good an
opening can be that white where you
actually win in five moves
and i'm going to show you why this
bishop already was
covering the c7 square
since the c pawn is gone and the knight
can't cover that c7 anymore from a6
the knight b5 jump actually is coming
with full power if queen a5
check you're just blocked and you can't
really capture that knight because this
bishop
is defending it so knight c7 is coming
fork down and it's game over the only
thing that you can do is play e5
but then d take c5 and you're going to
lose
one more pawn and being up two pawns in
the opening
is not such a bad deal
and that is kind of one of those little
tricks of
the rapport jabava not only
can you win in five moves you also get
tricky options so a6 obviously was
played by
emil sutovsky stopping this knight b5
move knight f3 now
they're apart from the positives like
these knight b5 tricks
which makes this kind of a fun variation
there's a little bit of a downside
because there's no more tension in the
center anymore
the play becomes a little bit dry but
you're going to
see how rapport treats this position
like it's the sharpest sicilian you've
ever seen
so sutovsky realizing that this bishop
is doing
absolutely nothing you play at bishop g4
also if you play knight c6 then there's
knight e5 and no longer
can you pin the knight therefore
sutowsky played
bishop g4 instead and here comes the big
move
h3 he's not hesitating richard is not
hesitating here
he's asking where your bishop is going
if you go bishop h5 you do run into g4
and knight e5 and that bishop just
doesn't feel comfortable
and oftentimes h4 can be very powerful
so if black plays e6 immediately
you can play h4 and white just
is going to ruin black structure and is
on the verge of getting a big advantage
so seeing this sutovsky took on f3
queen f3 knight c6 and if you can
predict the next move based on
the identity of the white player what
would that move be
what is the big move
long castles and that is one of those
staple rapport type of play he
always goes for the jugular he's a very
aggressive player and plays
this rapport jebaba system
like it's a chigoran up a tempo
e6 g4 and i'm mentioning it
because jabova's style is a little bit
different
now he's also an aggressive player but
he can mix it up as we will see
in the upcoming games
bishop b4 now on the surface this looks
very dangerous for the white king knight
e2
and satovsky actually falls for the bait
and he's trying to be very aggressive
and tries to attack those
queen side pawns king b1
knight e4 and it looks very dangerous
however rob board's next move
allah bent larson will defend everything
and there'll be no more problems
in this position for white
so often times the a pawn can be a
problem
but if white can over defend on the
queen side
then it'll be okay
c3 would actually weaken these pawns
so just keep one thing in mind
once you move upon in front of your king
it's much much easier to attack you
let's say you play a3
bishop e7 you can often get hit by b5 b4
and that's something you don't want to
see
and that'll be a problem and black can
get the big
attack going
and the big move is knight c1
very similar to ben larson's knight f8
defensive idea after knight c1
you cannot be checkmated or at least
it's very
difficult to get mated note
even if you go knight c3 that's not a
big deal
you can't capture and the knight will
always be
ready there to hop so the only threat
here would be
getting the the queen to b2
because there is no threats on the a2
pawn whenever you have a knight on c1
so there's a stroke d3 and this bishop
will have to leave
actually knight b3 is probably much more
simple
and simpler because you don't have queen
a3 because there's queen takes c3
long range move but wins the game
so seeing that there's no way he can
break through
he gave the option of exchanging the
bishop
so bishop d6 however knight b3 was
played queen c7
and bishop e3 again a very stylish move
by richard as he's aiming to keep
his vice alive that bishop bear if you
would have taken on d6
queen d6 and this knight is a monster
and also
because of the close nature of the
position you
can't really do anything or do too much
so bishop e3 is a better move keeping
the tension
and hopes to get the bishop to d3
let's stop here just for a second
in order to understand an opening you've
got to understand the ideas
so if we look at this position
what do you think will be the long-term
plan for white
in this position in this specific case
which side of the board are we going to
play at queenside kingside
pawn storm on the king side i see
yep we're going to play on the king side
because
we have more pawns and already a g4 pawn
kind of grabbing space so it's just
logical that we're going to go in that
direction
and satovsky makes a typical move
of castling which is normal
in a sicilian however you
really need to
focus whenever your opponent pawns are
ready
to attack with g5 and h4 you should
think twice
if you just castle into the attack as so
we say
rook g1 just getting
ready to pounce just like a ball seeing
a red flag
b5 bishop d3
little moves but first
rapport knows to connect the rooks so
there's no disharmony between the pieces
also
he makes sure that there's enough
pressure on that knight
so gonna try g5 but then maybe that
would run into f5
and it's not that clear yet and if you
go back
knight f6 then i can go g5 knight d7 h4
and who's faster obviously it's
white those pawns are very fast and
they're roaming down the board
but sutovsky is known to be a fighter
just like rapport and he says no i'm
gonna fight
i'm gonna play f5 bolster this night on
e4
and everything's great
however it turns out
that this was too much and it's rapport
to move
and show some fantastic technical
tactical vision that is he is going to
show some fantastic tactical vision
obviously we're going to take here if
rook takes f5
you do run into queen g2 and there are
many problems
e takes f5 we're getting
closer to rapport's magnificent
sacrifice so try to move
and crash through
yep you've got to go bishop h6
we've got to put pressure on the king
and that's very logical
if your opponent's king is just a little
bit exposed you've got to all the way
and just attack
rook f7 seemingly everything's all right
but here comes the punch
here comes the big punch line
boom bishop takes g7 out of the blue
he sacrifices the bishop because he
notices one little detail rook takes
queen takes f5 so let me start with
the count rapport has
two pawns for a piece which is not like
full compensation
however he already has his rooks
ready to double on the g file
and there are many loose pieces
so that rook is a little bit loose if it
gets exposed
it might be won by the queen
and even queen d5 is threatening to take
not just the pawn but the e4 knight
so the third pawn is hanging and the
attack is
still raging so knight e7
is a possible move however this
runs into queen e6
check here rook takes
king takes check again and if you go in
the corner
there's a simple but elegant solution
here
so let's try to find it
the king is already in big big trouble
it's cornered one check can
ruin the whole day for the black armada
bishop takes eliminating this
knight which defended the f6 square
after de queen f6
checkmates so knight e7
probably the most natural possible move
here is failing because of that queen e6
take six rook g1 and bishop e4 idea
so sutowsky is hiding he is going to
hide instead
so knowing what we already know should
be
able to find the next move
remember the d5 pawn is super weak
but if you can combine it with an attack
it will be even more successful
well if you take the knight it's a
different situation
because black still has coordination in
his position
that rook is well defended and rook g8
is coming
so if you're not careful sutovsky will
wriggle out
rook takes g7 why
because he would be happy to see king
takes check
here and bishop takes c4 with the same
idea
however if you take with the queen has
happened in the game because
satovsky just doesn't have a better
choice then we have queen takes d5 and
there's a big difference
in the other case if you take now this
knight is defended by the queen
so black can't go knight f6 and just
attack the queen
however after rook takes queen takes
queen takes d5
the queen is hitting a jackpot as it not
only hits the knight on c6
it kind of x-rays through to a8 and e4
as well
so rook takes g7 is by all means the
best move
trying to discoordinate sutovsky's
pieces
knight takes f2 queen takes c6
and this is kind of typical rapport
sharp
calculation you thought you could win
that rook however you really can't
because
that a8 rook is hanging and then there's
just too many pawns
dropping let's say here takes
and you don't really have this check
which would be nice
playing for back rank because after bc
check
white can just go king b2 and there's no
checkmate
so here satovski's agony is just
starting plays rook f8
so white can still take on d6 because
the d1 rook is hanging
just to do something else plays rook c1
but let's just
start counting pawns so
according to the pawn counts
white has two extra pawns that's not a
bad thing and we're
just on move 25 that's not a bad result
against emil sutowsky who's 26
24 at the time so a very strong
grand master having a winning position
after 25 moves
is a wonderful accomplishment
knight d3 cd queen g3 however
he did succeed in creating a double
pawns
the problem is not only your down two
pawns your king is
just awful in the corner
a3 saying hey you can take the pawn but
at least
i can hide my king away and then i'll
start capturing and going all pac-man on
your pawns on
a6 and b5 bishop f4
rook d1 queen h3 knight c5
just activating the knight defending
that pawn on d3
which was kind of loose before
bishop e3 queen e4 and
actually richard is showing something
that's very important
even when you have a winning position
the basic chess principles
should guide you so he activates the
knight
that is on c5 on a beautiful
outpost while queen e4 is also
lording down the board in the middle of
the board
namely the center
so no wonder that he's near winning
in this position queen f3 so satovsky's
seeing that there's
danger big danger in the position he's
aiming to exchange all of the pieces
queen e5
check but obviously raw port doesn't
want any of that
why because take sticks then the h-pawn
can run down on the board and it can get
double-edged
queen e5 king g8 rookie one
also he notices that his king is just
way better
than sutovsky is on g8 bishop
f2 rookie four queen f5
queen c7 still no exchanges even
threatening to double
on the seventh king h8
knight e6 rook g8 d5
bishop h4 queen c5
again centralizing everything
centralized
making sure everything is defended
bishop f6
king a2 look at that
all of white pieces are defending each
other
apart from the d-pawn but it's very hard
to get close to that one
h5 rook f4 queen g6
d6 and after queen d5 ideas this d-pawn
can start rushing
so this is kind of the beginning of the
end
bishop g7 so this time
rapport changes space plays queen f5
because he's actually hoping just to
promote
so by now the pawn has moved from
d4 to d6 and that means
it's just two moves away from queening
so it says
okay in this case i'm happy to exchange
queens
king gate 7 d7 and because
this f6 square is guarded by the queen
and the rook
there's no way of stopping that
promotion
queen takes rook takes f5 king g6
and the icing of the cake
is the last move that richard rapport
played
so channel your inner richard rapport
and you'll find this beautiful finishing
touch
why to move and win the game
well elegance is an attitude
and rook f8 was played
beautiful beautiful solution the point
is
either you're going to lose that rook
or if you take then i can just promote
on
d8 and i'm up a queen there's no hope
there
and a few takes knight takes and queens
so after rook f8 sutovsky resigned
not a bad start for this fledgling
opening of the robot jobova
system or variation that's a good start
but let's get going to the next one
so let's take a look now
how mr badur
joe bava plays this system
how he does and plays
and in this game he's facing
the world champion vessel and topolov
knight f6 knight c3 d5
bishop f4 e6
now e6 is the other move but obviously
c5 is the critical
but we've already touched upon this one
in
the most important game rapport
sutovsky e6
knight b5 and if you can forgive me
i'm going to show a counterpart of this
one
so in the rati there's this system of d5
g3 knight c6 d4
bishop f5 and all of these ideas
obviously was
by s was sprung by richard rapport
and in fact with the help of his
fresney beat kramnik so bishop f5
bishop g2 knight b4 and this is a
typical idea
which was kind of picked up
later on by caruana
and of course morozevic who's a
chigorian player
now remember if you just rotate the
board
this is actually very much the same
as we're going to see in this game so
let's go back
knight c3 d5 e6
knight b5 exactly the same thing so the
whole point of knight b5 is the
following
he's attacking the c pawn if you play
bishop d6
you lose your bishop pair which is clear
would favor white so knight a6
is virtually the only move defending the
pawn
but then you can argue that this knight
is going to
look very dumb in the future on a6
a3 c6 knight c3
so even though jobava's knight on c3 is
not ideal
well what can we say about that knight
on a6 then well
what we can say that knight on a6 is
horrible
bishop d6 e3 so this is kind of
the slower way of playing this system
why not c4 because white is actually not
equipped for quick action because this
king is still in some sort of dangers of
checks after you play c4
you no longer have this move of c3
so bishop b4 check can be very dangerous
because the only move you can play there
say their bishop d2 or
back but even that can run into knight
e4
with uncomfortable complications
so a3 is actually an important move
stopping that bishop b4
idea and now knight c3 is a possibility
bishop d6 e3 and i was about to tell you
that
so rapport is the more aggressive type
in the report jabava system slash
variation
however jobava sometimes like to play it
like
it's more of a qgd so a queen's gambit
type of position
knight c7 knight f3 so what jibaba
claims in this position is the following
i have the e5 control and your knight is
not
very well placed on c7 bishop f4
e takes f4 now bishop takes f4 makes
sense
however it gives
away this all-important e5 square which
as we will see in the game will have a
negative
effect on topolov's position
between these six i don't know if i even
have to
ask you what you should be playing in
this position but i'm gonna do it
anyways
so what should we react black is
bothering our pawns on f4 how should we
deal
with this mortal question
well we should always play like a boss
like joe bava would
and obviously he plunked that knight on
e5
and that is not just a measly knight
it's a knight that's supported by two
pawns
that is a powerful outpost
right there v6
just hoping to do some exchanges in the
future
and just activate that in general
miserable bishop on c8
and that's actually one of the reasons
why this system can be very dangerous
for black because that c8 bishop still
has a long way to go till it gets
active queen f3 c5
and jabba's next move is kind of
more aggressive than good
so here he could have just gone castling
or rook d1
both of them are fine however both
rapport and jaba are concrete players
they like to go for action so he played
knight b5
and i'm not claiming that this is the
best move
but it does provide many practical
problems
pose many of those problems for
topolov note that the king is still in
the center
and a move away from castling however
jobava is going to try to capitalize on
that take stakes ship d7
knight takes d7 knight takes d7 and long
castle
so yes badur is thinking about taking on
d7
but not just yet he's waiting
if topalov is going to react to the fact
that this finn is sort of annoying
because even if topalov plays a6 now
that is
sort of a success from jabhava's
perspective
because he could go dc bc and c4
immediately hacking away and attacking
the d5 pawn
so often times when these
super ground masters don't take pieces
they just want to provoke you
to waste time or play moves such as a6
but topolov as we all know is the legend
and he's not going to waste time
on that ship takes d7
queen takes d7 and
jabova realizing that
king can be very dangerous in this case
because in the previous case
black did not really have time to
consolidate
so if you would take on c5 c4 that would
be very dicey in this position
so let's try to find jabava's next move
which will try to chip away
from the center
so even though this position might seem
a little bit
slow it's not if
black starts rolling and two moves
we can get in trouble so as white you've
got to be very aggressive
and be on point so whoever said f5
congratulations f5 is the big move here
why because if you take on f5 d takes c5
bc and i can take with the queen or the
rook it kind of depends on my
or your style i could go rook d5 try to
win this spawn
or go queen d5 in both cases
white will have very nice advantage the
king is already on the right side of the
board
where there's a potential for a past
pawn
so this is just ideal for an end game
now topolov obviously is not rooting
for the white pieces so he's going to
avoid that
play screen e7 a natural move
sidestepping pressure however
rook he one shows up simple
and strong and sometimes in chess you
don't
necessarily need to make astounding
moves
just moves that follow chess principles
bringing in your rook that did nothing
in the corner
simple just improve it and your
situation will get better
again if you would get greedy
which inches isn't necessarily a bad
thing
you'd face the same exact problem
you might lose some more pawns and we
get
this position right again the power of
centralization
and actually that's why i kind of adhere
to this
rapport jebavah variation
because it kind of shows you that you
need to centralize and if you do then
you'll
reap the rewards as you'll see in this
game rookie one
c takes d4 rook takes d4 queen f6
so black actually managed to keep it
intact so far
queen f4 just defending this rook
however queen f4 was a little bit
dangerous why because you do allow
some sort of ideas of e5 not quite yet
though
because i have two pieces covering the
e5 square
so naturally topolof plays rook e8
setting up e5 but joe bava
is not having any of that plays rook e5
and says no you're not gonna play it
not today at least rookie 5 and you can
see
that white has some nice little pressure
here
and for a second let's start thinking
strategically
so if black does nothing
what would be white's big plan in this
position
nimzo would indeed be very proud this
is the perfect blockade
you would start roaming the g4 g5
indeed warriors it is badour
joe bava the legendary player
yeah so in this specific case
even though black has a solid structure
he has no real plans or aggressive plans
so you can go g4 g5 and then there'll be
issues
as the attack will start rolling and
once
the f5 pawn reaches f6
nate is not far away so noticing that
topalov went into e takes f5
rook takes d5 rookie 5
rookie 5 g6 but then we kind of get
a typical sicilian situation where white
has an
extra pawn on the queen side and the
king
that will be much much closer
to those passers than this king on g8
which is oceans away
probably on a different continent
on g8 rookie two
so mission accomplished says jabava
i have the position that i wanted to get
so i'm just going to drop back
defend my second rank mcqueen is also
ready to pounce on c7
and just go and bother those pawns on a7
and b6
rook d8 queen e5
and these are those little details that
makes these grandmasters so good they
know these
they notice that the end game is perfect
for me
so queen exchange how about exchanging
queens
topalov is asked that question from jeb
bava
however vaseline topalov is saying
no no no no your king is really good in
the end game
however you're still in the middle game
and i want to
checkmate that fork on c1
so if i can still keep the queen on the
board bother maybe
your kingside pawns i might get some
country chances
so to be honest with you this position
is probably
balanced but it's not a draw why because
if white does manage to exchange of the
queens
white will get the advantage because he
will have
more potential to create a passer what
about black well black has the chance to
put pressure on these spawns
or create some threats against the king
let's see what happened
f3 just defending all these pawns
making sure vessel doesn't have any
funny business going on
a5 b3 b5
king b2 so
b3 king b2 by the way was prepared
well in advance by jobava if
you would have done that earlier this
would be checkmate
so you can tell how dangerous this can
be you can get mated in one move if
the move order is wrong so queen e5 was
important
between c6 f3 a5 b3 and he's just
building a little cave for that king on
b2
king b2 a4 does white really want
the position to open up in front of the
king not at all
just going to play b4 queen c4
and probably queen c4 was a little bit
over zealous
by the world champion ex-world champion
from this moment if because we're
talking from 2020
as magnus is the reigning champion right
now
he should have gone rook c8 instead and
put pressure
on the c file not that he's going to get
an advantage
but probably he has enough counter play
on this king that the position still
keeps
being balanced however queen c4 is going
a little bit overboard
he's trying to get behind the white
pieces and try to smoke out the king on
b2
rook three and this is kind of those
cheeky moves by joe bava he's saying
okay go ahead go ahead in there
i don't believe that's such a big danger
queen f1 rookie 2 saying the queen is
actually misplaced on f1
it does not that much rook d1
boom takes the pawn and says hey
i will hide my king on c3 and your king
on the other hand is without any
defenders
the whole army of yours is still on the
back rank
king c3 king g7
rook even actually which seems kind of
dangerous
could run into this nice little move of
rookie a check
and you can't quite capture it because
the queen
would be lost on f1
so topalov decides to flee with his
monarch king g7 check
queen e3 king g7 and
we already know what we're supposed to
do as white
we are up upon an end game would be
brilliant
so can you guess what badour played in
this position
once you know the goal of the game it's
much much easier to find the moves
yes of course queen f2 cheekily
offering the exchange of queens and in
that case
this b-pawn with the help of the king
and that's what i was talking about
this king is just much stronger than its
counterpart
it's just ready to support this pawn on
b4
it's like here here i can go b5
and when you come closer i'll cut you
off
and you can't come closer and this king
will win the game
alone together with that pawn
so clean age one obviously topalov wants
none of that
but then this queen is very awkward in
that corner
in d4 making h6 rook e7
queen takes g2 and now
let's find the move that joe bava played
never forget what we're playing for
now we're playing for an end game queen
d2 check
takes king takes d2 and
after rook a1 there was this move of
rookie 1
ok 3 b5 and even though this
rook seems active it is kind of cut
off from defending and stopping that b
fun
b-pawn from running it's very difficult
to stop that b-pawn from running
and if you go rk2 rugby one
and that pawn will march and turn into
a lady so that was one of those
typical wins by ajabava
playing very solidly not going for that
deep of complications however still
playing energetically
and looking for the opportunities to use
the positional vices
but i feel we didn't see enough of joba
so let's look at one more of his games
where he faced ruslan ponomariov
so we're looking at this game
by jabava where he actually will be
playing more
in the style of queen's gambit decline
so whenever i'm talking about queen's
gambit declined
whenever you see positions like this
c takes e takes knight f3 knight f6
bishop g5 and you get into slow
maneuvering bishop e6
so let's say castles e3 bishop e6
knight d7 and this typical play
in the opening so the rapport jabava
as it is correctly named he plays it
differently at times with bishop f4
c5 now he's facing what rapport faced
e3 c takes d4 e takes d4
again you don't have knight c6 because
the same trick
it's the same deal a6 bishop d3
so we've seen knight f3 in the original
rapport sutovsky game
bishop d3 knight c6 also coming back to
that side note
so it's kind of fascinating we're
writing 2020 now
however this whole system by rapport and
joba
was invented only six years ago so in
2014
and was played by the rapport
so rapport and his wife
johanna and
jobava badur jobava so here
this time he makes it up and goes knight
e2
which is surprising totally different
way of playing
and more of a slow positional grind
but let's see what's going on e6
and e6 i don't think is such a great
move because
in the french and in any other openings
the big issue
what are you going to do with that c8
bishop so probably
bishop g4 should have been much better
and just activate it and try to exchange
it off because after e6 that bishop
is just staring into nothingness
queen d2 b5 but this time jebaba
is tricking you with the mirage that
he's going to castle along
he's actually castling short bishop e7
but b4 is still an annoying move so i'm
going to deal with it with a3
bishop d7 h3
castle and now we have to design and
this is one of those
important questions in chess that you
have to answer
which rook to activate or where to put
them
so let's talk about this a little bit
where would you put
your rook or which one would you put
where
in fact this can decide if you win or
lose a game
the placement of your rooks so here it's
even more important
well if you ask me i would put the rook
to d1
and the other rook to e1 the problem is
if you go
rook a1 this rook is not doing that much
and f4 f5 even though looks tempting
to be honest with you is just very hard
to achieve
noticing that jobava actually goes rook
fe1 and bringing the other rook to d1
just remember you also have a weakness
on d4
and because of your knight is on c3
oftentimes
the spawn on d4 can get into trouble so
it makes sense to have a rook
supporting it from d1
knight a5 rogue d1
queen b6 and again
here i'm going to stop and ask you the
big question
all right we have all of our pieces
in good positions however you've got to
continue playing the game you can just
say stop
i'm good i'm happy what's going on in
this position
i'm passing it doesn't work like that in
chess
you can't pass you still got to find a
plan
and the way grand masters find plan is a
following
which plea which piece is terrible at
the moment
well it's the knight on e2 so
jobava was thinking and saying well i
don't want to put this knight on c1
because it wouldn't do too well on that
square
so it goes die g3 the question is
what is this knight really doing on g3
so that's the one thing that ponomario
was
probably wondering what is that
knight actually trying to do rook fc8
said
just brought the rook to the c file said
i don't see
i don't know what you really want so
you know you tell me you tell me
what you want however
ponomariov is going to be
surprised it's white to move
and play let's try to find jobaba's
brilliant brilliant move
so whenever you're looking for
improbable solutions
or tactics you always have to pinpoint
the weakness
in this position and the weakness in
this position
is this bishop on e7 now it's covered
by these pawns however not after knight
f5
it's not because if you take then
there's rook takes e7
let's put the mario of thought here okay
i'll take
takes bishop e6 and after queen d8
i will go all pac-man on that rook
on e7 and thinking that
this will be his day just winning the
rook
and winning a game against jobava but it
turns out
that's not the case because
jebovah unleashes this unpredictable but
brilliant move of bishop h6
unpredictable but not illogical mind you
why because the queen the knight
the rooks are sort of on a vacation
on the queen side and there's not really
any pieces left
defending the king and if the king would
try to run
well it wouldn't run for too long long
because bishop g7
queen g5 check and then you lose
the knight also your king is awful
also if you take this queen takes h6
let's say knight e8
then there's a beautiful finish so i
don't really want to spoil it for you
dear viewers
i'll give you a little bit of time to
find it because this one is just
beautiful
well you can go the easy way
but you can also do a cascade of
sacrifices
knight takes d5 you can't
take that knight because this long range
piece called
the queen is going to take you from h6
all
to b6
queen d8 seemingly defending everything
but not for too long boom rook takes c8
you've got to take only move knight f6
royal fork but we're not even gonna take
that lady
because it's made on h7
very very elegant way to finish the game
however he didn't take
and didn't play knight e8 he actually
took but he didn't play knight e8
this is a gorgeous mate i have to be
honest with you
and by the way bishop h6 again we are on
move
17. so this is a big
and quick attacking game by badur
joe bava gh queen takes h6
rook takes c3 and here
instead of taking this rook he says
no no no i don't want your rook check
king f8
queen takes rook takes
d c d and here black resigned however
i'll tell you the reason why you can't
ever go back with the knight
because then you lose the bishop your
pawn is pinned on f7
and if you don't do that white is just
going to play
rook e1 rook takes e6 regardless of what
you do
if you go here might still doesn't care
rook takes e6 this is kind of beautiful
with all of those heavy pieces
mounting in front of the king rook takes
e6
and queen takes f7 checkmate so that is
kind of the
reason that ruslan ponomariov
resigned on move 21
and probably this is the reason what you
see on
the board so that will be it
for the rapport jabava variation and i
really hope
that i gave you a boost to pick it up
and appreciate and spread the word that
this
is the rapport jobalva variation that
you so much
love and want to play thank you for
listening and watching
take care
you